[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american
psychological thriller film called the
quiet
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
dot is a deaf and mute high school girl
because of her disability she hardly has
any friends and is always alone after
the recent death of dot's single father
her godmother's family has been taking
care of her her new god sister nina is
not accustomed to having a sister and
hates dot for no reason the two go to
the same school where dodd is a social
outcast while nina is one of the popular
girls in the opening scene nina and her
group of mean cheerleaders make fun of
dot's disability the school's guidance
counselor sees this and asks dot to join
her table for lunch dot refuses and runs
to her favorite spot in the school a
bathroom stall she feels safe and much
less lonely when she is alone her
happiness doesn't last long though
because nina finds her and angrily pulls
her out for the ride home nina's mother
olivia encourages her daughter to make
thought feel at home but nina cannot
care less since it wasn't her decision
to take her in she doesn't feel
responsible to do dot any favors in the
evening nina's father paul arrives home
and finds olivia passed out in the
living room she has a drinking problem
and suffers from depression because
she's on several antidepressants paul
takes care of her and gets her to bed on
returning back to the dinner table he
notices an awkward silence between the
girls to cut the tension he suggests
they learn sign language for dot but
nina cuts him off and walks away the
following day during lunch nina and her
friends are gossiping as usual her
friend michelle brings up the topic of
virginity and makes fun of nina for
being a 17 year old virgin she can have
any guy she wants but is reserved when
it comes to dating meanwhile doc comes
across the school's empty music room and
takes the opportunity to play piano she
used to practice when she was still
hearing hence she plays pretty well even
without hearing the music one of the
popular guys connor hears her play and
is instantly smitten by her he stares at
her for a long time before pulling away
when his friend interrupts later dot
meets nina in the washroom she tries to
mind her own business but nina
forcefully makes her wear lipstick just
when dot thinks that this might be a
bonding moment for them she looks into
the mirror and discovers that nina
purposely smeared lipstick around her
lips that night dot has a hard time
falling asleep because she misses her
father when she comes outside to get
some fresh air she notices nina's
bedroom door is open on peeking she sees
nina and her father paul together in bed
the sight disturbs her to her core
making her run right back to her room
i'm not going to make a joke about that
scene the next day at dinner nina asks
her parents for permission to spend the
night at michelle's paul doesn't allow
her but olivia encourages her to go when
paul stays adamant nina rubs her feet up
his leg under the table trying to seduce
him into letting her go he doesn't say
anything which she takes as a yes and
calls michelle paul is mad at olivia for
always contradicting him they get into a
slight argument before he walks away
when olivia is alone dot hands her a
note asking if she can go to the movies
paul offers to drive her there and dodd
agrees even though she's uncomfortable
the movie hall is empty except for nina
and her squad in the middle row connor
sees dot sitting alone and wants to
approach her but the others stop him
nina feels somewhat bad for her but
keeps on the act that she doesn't care
doc catches her slipping when she closes
her ears to see how it feels to be deaf
but she stops upon noticing dots staring
down at her later at night dot stays
awake thinking about her last encounter
with nina suddenly she notices paul
coming downstairs and pretends to be
asleep he strokes her hair and calls
himself sick he seems to know what he is
doing with his daughter is wrong but
cannot stop after coming this far he
agreed to take dot in thinking that her
presence might stop him from going into
nina's room but it clearly didn't help
in the following scene dot is home alone
playing on the piano unbeknownst to her
nina arrives home from school and
watches her play from the doorway
suddenly a piano wire snaps making doc
curse out loud
[ __ ]
nina freezes in shock realizing that dot
could hear them all this time she
pretends to have just gotten home and
doesn't call her out on the lie the next
day at lunch nina sits with dot for the
first time as dot looks at her in
confusion nina begins explaining little
details about her private time with her
father she is clearly doing it to get a
reaction out of her but dot remains calm
before leaving she also claims that she
is going to use michelle's gun to kill
paul at night dot still doesn't give her
the attention she wants but is afraid
that she might be telling the truth to
get her mind off nina she goes to the
music room again to play piano this time
she notices connor staring at her
through the door she gets nervous and
tries to leave but the guy stops her he
asks her out on a date to work on a lab
report together his plan fails when she
shows him the already completed report
that night the family is enjoying dinner
together when connor knocks at the door
surprising everyone he asks dot to come
to the library to go over the lab report
she reluctantly agrees just when
michelle arrives and hands a bag to nina
dot remembers that nina mentioned
michelle's gun and is nervous that she
might actually be planning to kill paul
in the following scene dot and connor
are at a diner he talks to her about the
report for a few seconds but eventually
tells her how he feels about her
thinking that she cannot hear him he
shares details about how he imagines
making love to her suddenly dot notices
an ambulance drive towards her house and
assumes that nina has done something bad
she rushes home and is relieved to see
that everyone is safe following that she
walks towards nina's room and hears paul
undressing her nina clearly sounds sick
of her father's behavior so to help her
dot breaks a statue the noise interrupts
the commotion and paul returns to his
room nina is left in her bed crying when
dot slips into the bed and holds her and
she goes to sleep in the following scene
nina is ironing her cheer uniform while
talking to dodd she promises to kill
paul that night with the iron and burns
the face off a teddy bear for effect dot
still gets the impression that nina
doesn't know she can hear hence she
pretends to have not heard her plan
later that day nina and michelle cheer
for the school's basketball team conor
is on the team but is so bad that the
coach sends him to the bench in the
first few minutes after the game connor
and doc go by the pool and spend some
time together conor thinks that she
cannot hear him and starts talking about
his sex life suddenly dot takes off her
top and the two make love by the pool
meanwhile at home olivia suggests that
nina and connor would make a great
couple the comment makes paul mad as he
accuses her of making her daughter dress
like a [ __ ] as they chat olivia takes
her clothes off and invites him to bed
but connor no longer feels attracted to
her she's not a teenager after all nina
returns home at midnight and is tired
after cheering the entire day paul gives
her a handbag as a gift and makes
advances at her we also notice that
olivia is awake in her bedroom she seems
to know what is going on but still does
nothing to stop her husband nina asks
paul to close his eyes as she has a
surprise for him when he does is told
she approaches him with a hot iron she
is seconds away from burning his face
but right then dot returns home and
interrupts them nina pulls back and
claims that she is pregnant paul is
horrified at the thought of fathering
his own grandchild hence when nina asks
him for a thousand dollars for an
abortion he agrees to hand it to her the
next day following that nina goes to
dot's room and confesses that she wasn't
brave enough to kill him the next day is
the school dance nina lends dot a dress
for the night as the girls get ready she
reveals that she lied about being
pregnant in reality she plans to take
the thousand bucks and run away to a
different state she hopes to become a
stripper and make a lot of money in a
new city after confessing she applies
lipstick to dot this time without making
her look like a clown a while later paul
is looking for nina when he finds
tampons in her bag she had said that she
hasn't gotten her period in over six
weeks so this makes him believe she's
lying about the pregnancy he shows her
the tampons and asks her to tell the
truth nina tries to make up a lie but he
doesn't buy it he starts to slap her
face and force himself on her olivia
hears her daughter crying in pain but
does nothing dot also hears the crying
and screaming she stops playing rips out
a piano wire and walks to the bedroom
while paul is busy she strangles him
with the wire while screaming at him to
leave nina alone seconds later she stops
and he falls dead to the ground nina is
in shock she curses dot for killing her
daddy when olivia comes upstairs she is
more shocked about dot knowing how to
speak than her husband being dead at the
same time michelle rings the doorbell to
pick them up for the school dance the
girls quickly change their clothes and
keep the bloodied ones inside a bag
following that they take the bag and go
to school to make it seem like
everything is normal at school dot
dances with connor but is too distracted
to pay attention to him nina takes the
backpack and hides in the bathroom stall
waiting for the party to be over
meanwhile olivia is in the bedroom
staring at paul's dead body with an
expressionless face she had fallen out
of love with him a long time ago the
only thing she regrets is not being
brave enough to save her daughter from a
monster like him somewhere else conor
calls dot's name as she is leaving the
party and is shocked to see her turn
around he discovers that she can
actually hear him with the revelation he
also realizes that she knows all of his
dirty secrets he calls her a psycho for
betraying him and violating his privacy
dot tries to apologize but is shoved off
knowing that he won't give her a chance
at this moment she focuses on more
important matters she gets nina from the
bathroom and takes her to a nearby creek
they bury the backpack with the clothes
planning to get rid of the body later
when nina asks dot why she pretended to
be deaf all this time she replies that
she wanted to be like her father who was
also deaf and mute the girls then
quickly rush home to the biggest
surprise of all their house is
surrounded by police and olivia is being
escorted out in handcuffs they ask what
happened to which olivia claims that she
killed paul
she also apologizes to nina for what she
did while the police think it's because
she killed her father nina understands
the real reason behind the apology in
the final scene the girls watch as the
police take olivia away in the car the
punishment would have been much less
severe if the daughter had taken the
heat subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching